y
[Música]
al iniciar la reunión del consejo
europeo- ursula von der leyen anunció un
plan de emergencia en caso de que no se
llegue a un acuerdo post break si la
iniciativa se centra en temas como
seguridad aérea pesca y transportes
terrestres el bloque y reino unido-
continuarán negociando un posible pacto
hasta el domingo
hoy se celebra el día internacional de
los derechos humanos naciones unidas-
hizo un llamado para que tras la
pandemia los lideres se centren en
proteger a todas las personas sin
discriminación en pleno 2020 del
colectivo lgtb y continúa siendo uno de
los más excluidos y perseguidos del
mundo varias ong piden que sus derechos
sean reconocidos y respetados
la cámara de diputados de argentina debe
votar hoy el proyecto de ley de acceso
al aborto la iniciativa cuenta con el
respaldo del gobierno y es impulsada por
el presidente alberto fernández la
discusión se presenta en el mismo día en
que el mandatario cumple un difícil año
en el poder
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torre sánchez iniciamos esta emisión de
noticias en europa porque la unión
europea presentó un plan de emergencia
ante la posibilidad de que no se logre
un acuerdo post break sheet con reino
unido la iniciativa se centra en cuatro
puntos específicos las conexiones aéreas
fundamentales con reino unido la
seguridad aérea los transportes
terrestres y un marco legal sobre pesca
la medida anunciada por la presidenta de
la comisión europea ursula von der leyen
se conoce luego de que se anunciara que
el bloque y los británicos continuarán
negociando hasta el lunes hasta el
domingo la líder europea y el primer
ministro británico boris johnson se
reunieron por más de tres horas anoche
en bruselas e indicaron que las
diferencias siguen siendo muy grandes en
asuntos clave
tuvimos una discusión animada e
interesante sobre el estado en el que se
encuentran los temas pendientes
entendemos las posiciones de cada uno
éstas permanecen alejadas los equipos
deben volver a reunirse de inmediato
para tratar de resolver estos asuntos
llegaremos a una decisión para el final
del fin de semana de europa vamos a eeuu
hay gran expectativa por la decisión de
la administración de medicamentos y
alimentos fda por sus siglas en inglés
que en las próximas horas podría otorgar
la autorización de emergencia a la
vacuna de facer y bayonne tec contra el
hobbit 19 esto cuando el país rompió una
vez más el récord de muertes con 3 mil
53 fallecimientos en las últimas 24
horas y se registraron más de 218 mil
contagios esto es lo que analizará la
sda para determinar si autoriza o no el
uso de emergencia
la reunión está siendo convocada para
discutir si basado en la totalidad de la
evidencia científica disponible es
razonable creer que la vacuna contra el
coi 19 de facer bayón tec puede ser
efectiva para prevenir el cob y 19 en
individuos de 16 años o de más edad y si
los beneficios potenciales y conocidos
de la vacuna pesan más que sus riesgos
potenciales y conocidos para el uso en
individuos de 16 años o mayores hoy se
conmemora el día internacional de los
derechos humanos el secretario general
de la onu antonio guterres pidió a los
líderes mundiales que tras superar la
pandemia los esfuerzos se centren en el
respeto y reconocimiento de los derechos
de todas las personas uno de los
colectivos más discriminados y
perseguidos en el mundo es el ltte vie
en pleno 2020 la homosexualidad es
penada en hasta 69 países de los cuales
entonces se condena a muerte veamos más
detalles
en el informe de álvaro cordero
jazzy carolina es una mujer trans
colombiana que se vio obligada a huir de
su país aunque colombia es un estado que
posee protecciones amplias del colectivo
lgtb y ella sufrió discriminación
laboral y un rechazo familiar profundo
por su condición tenía mucho maltrato de
parte de mi jefe por mi condición y mi
identidad sexual
digamos que de mi familia tampoco tuve
el apoyo mi madre en algún momento
decidió sencillamente decirme
no estamos parado para esto a veces es
un poco fuerte para estas personas
muchas veces su mayor terror se
encuentra en su propia casa ya que hay
progenitores que deciden enviar a sus
hijos a terapias de reconversión sexual
estos pseudo tratamientos no tienen base
científica y por el contrario pueden
causar graves daños psíquicos y físicos
a las personas que son sometidos a ellos
sin embargo solamente son ilegales de
forma total en cuatro países y de forma
parcial en otros cinco en todo el mundo
pero la persecución hacia este colectivo
no se queda ahí en 12 países la
homosexualidad se castiga con la muerte
y en otros 57 con prisión la mayoría de
estas penas se concentran en áfrica y
medio oriente aunque también se dan en
américa y asia esto hace que las
solicitudes de asilo por la condición u
orientación sexual sean cada vez más
habituales algo que ha hecho que en
países como españa ya se hayan abierto
centros de acogida este centro lo que
les da es un poco esa libertad no de
sentirse de sentirse ellos mismos y
poder estar en un espacio seguro aunque
los países que protegen los derechos del
colectivo lgtb son cada vez más cada año
siguen asesinando
de personas por su orientación y
condición sexual la cámara de diputados
de argentina iniciará hoy la discusión
del proyecto de ley de interrupción del
embarazo es la segunda vez que el
congreso debatirá la normativa que
fracasó en 2018 por decisión del senado
pero es la primera vez que la iniciativa
es directamente del presidente el
proyecto permite que el acceso a la
huerto se produzca hasta la semana 14 de
gestación y más allá si hubo violación o
si la vida de la madre corre peligro la
iniciativa también incluye un proyecto
de ley sobre cuidado integral de la
salud durante el embarazo y la primera
infancia presidente alberto fernández
que justamente hoy cumple un año desde
su llegada al poder impulsó está este
proyecto veamos más en el informe de
luís muñoz
un año después entre la esperanza y la
resignación
alberto fernández llegó al poder en
argentina para recuperar la maltratada
economía del país algo que no ha
sucedido a la crisis heredada se sumó la
pandemia del cob y 19 a toda la
argentina a todos los argentinos a todas
las argentinas a partir de la cero hora
de mañana deberán someterse al
aislamiento social preventivo y
obligatorio una respuesta al coronavirus
que empezó siendo admirada pero que lo
ha ido desgastando pese a uno de los
confinamientos más largos del mundo
argentina es el tercer país de américa
latina con más muertes tampoco ha
logrado iniciar la recuperación
económica aunque se han visto sus
intentos de llevar a cabo una política
social con las ayudas de pandemia una
novedosa ley de impuestos a los ricos
rechazada por la oposición ligada al
presidente macri por los afectados
además del impulso directamente desde
presidencia de la ley de legalización
del aborto enviaré a el congreso de la
nación para su tratamiento
dos proyectos de ley para que todas las
mujeres accedan al derecho a la salud
integral un hito de gobierno que
comparte con la reestructuración de la
deuda y la renegociación con el fmi con
la que consiguió extender vencimientos
de pago y reducir las tasas de interés
aunque el problema de la deuda dista de
estar resuelto y que hoy con
tranquilidad podemos decir que el
objetivo que nos fijamos lo hemos
logrado
para la argentina el acuerdo que hemos
alcanzado significan 37 mil 700 millones
de dólares menos que deberemos pagar en
los próximos 10 años en política
internacional este primer año podría dar
lugar a un liderazgo de argentina en el
mercosur
fernández se ha acercado al presidente
de brasil their bolsonaro para forjar
alianzas en la región
aunque la oposición lo acusa de haberse
kids en izado son evidentes las
distancias con la antigua mandataria y
ahora vicepresidenta cristina fernández
de kirchner
bajo cuya sombra ha gobernado este año
2021 servirá para comprobar si se
confirman las expectativas previas a su
elección o bien en los comicios de mitad
de mandato vuelve a haber un giro
político en el país un reto que en buena
medida dependerá de la gestión de la
vacunación que él quiere convertir en
una epopeya porque alberto fernández no
será juzgado tanto por lo que prometió
sino por lo que le tocó como él mismo
dijo somos los gobernantes de la
pandemia y así nos recordarán
volvemos a europa el juicio del ex
presidente francés nicolas sarkozy
finaliza en las próximas horas la
defensa insiste en que las acusaciones
en contra del exmandatario carecen de
contenido y pidió su absolución mientras
que la fiscalía solicitó cuatro años de
cárcel 12 en prisión y 2 en libertad
condicional
sarkozy es acusado de corrupción y
tráfico de influencias
luego que prometiera un ascenso a un
magistrado del tribunal supremo a cambio
de información confidencial sobre otra
investigación en la que estaba implicado
a esta hora conectamos con nuestra
corresponsal en parís natalia ruiz
natalia buenos días cuando se esperaría
un veredicto contra el expresidente
francés
muy buenos días pues la audiencia de hoy
debe estar por comenzar en los próximos
instantes se espera primero pues que se
terminen los argumentos o finales de la
defensa tanto de thiago como de
veracidad que son los dos otros acusados
en este caso los de nicolas sarkozy
tuvieron lugar ayer cuando su abogada es
reactiva de la fvm pidió a la corte una
justicia libre al término de esto se le
dará la palabra a los tres acusados y
luego será la presidenta de esta corte
de decidir si van a entrar a deliberar o
no pero lo cierto es que el fallo puede
que no se conozca hoy sino que se demore
varios días e incluso semanas antes de
determinar si la corte va a fallar a
favor o no de la fiscalía que pidió como
usted lo decía esos o cuatro años de
cárcel
natalia y este proceso ha dividido a la
justicia en francia y sarkozy aún tiene
pendientes otras investigaciones
cuéntenos más al respecto
así es pues la verdad es que ha sido
sobre todo sobre lo que ha basado la
fiscalía para acusar tanto de corrupción
como de tráfico de influencias a estas
tres personas porque se trata de las
escuchas telefónicas y para el colegio
de abogados de parís se trata de una
violación del secreto profesional porque
se trata de conversaciones entre nicolas
sarkozy y su abogado de hecho este
colegio de abogados ha hecho presencia
durante las audiencias de este caso
desde la semana pasada para demostrar su
apoyo a la defensa y por otra parte pues
ha sido el fiscal que dirige la fiscalía
nacionales de finanzas la que ha venido
a apoyar a sus dos fiscales a cargo pues
de la acusación en este caso así que
como ustedes ven este caso también ha
dividido de alguna manera la justicia
acá nicolas sarkozy tiene todavía
cuentas pendientes con la justicia por
una parte sobre la financiación ilegal
de su campaña a la presidencia del 2007
todavía se investiga si recibió o no
tire dineros ilícitos de el régimen
libio de general
y por otra parte pues hay otro proceso
que se si está mucho más adelantado que
debe comenzar el próximo 17 de marzo
sobre la financiación de su campaña de
reelección esta vez en el 2012 cuando se
utilizaron falsas facturas para tapar
que se habían pasado sobre el pasado los
topes de campaña que permite la ley aquí
en francia nos valía muchas gracias por
toda esta información estaremos muy
pendientes de lo que pueda ocurrir en la
audiencia en las pre los próximos
minutos en otras noticias facebook fue
demandado por 48 estados en eeuu y el
organismo regulador del comercio de ese
país
la red social está acusada de incumplir
las normas en favor de la libre
competencia por su parte el gigante
tecnológico considera que el gobierno
ignora los efectos de esta decisión
sobre la comunidad empresarial
'facebook de nuevo en el punto de mira
de la justicia esta vez han sido las
fiscalías de 48 estados y la autoridad
reguladora del comercio en eeuu la que
ha demandado a la compañía de mark
zuckerberg la acusan de infringir la
legislación en pro de la libre
competencia al haber mantenido
ilegalmente su monopolio del sector
particularmente con la compra de
eventuales rivales como instagram y
whatsapp
hoy actuamos y nos ponemos del lado de
millones de usuarios y pequeños negocios
que han sido perjudicados por la
conducta ilegal de facebook así que
pedimos a la corte que detenga e impida
a la compañía seguir haciéndolo en el
futuro exterior con that one
restableciendo la competencia del
mercado nuestra demanda ayudará a los
consumidores a tener alternativas a
facebook
la reacción de la empresa ubicada en
california ha sido rápida advierta al
gobierno federal del impacto sin
precedentes que esta iniciativa
supondría no sólo para las empresas sino
para los usuarios de la red facebook se
hizo con instagram en 2012 por mil
millones de dólares mientras que en 2014
absorbió whatsapp por un valor de 19 mil
millones de dólares ahora ante lo que
consideran como conductas anti com
que reducen las opciones del usuario los
demandantes piden que el tribunal
obligue a facebook a reestructurar su
negocio obligándolo a vender instagram y
whatsapp google fue también demandado en
octubre por el departamento de justicia
y amazon y apple han sido sometidas a
investigaciones federales también por
conductas anticompetitivas continuamos
en medio oriente
la periodista afgana malalai my world y
su conductor fueron asesinados por
desconocidos armados en la provincia
afgana de nangarhar en el este del país
ambos fueron asesinados a tiros cuando
la reportera se trasladaba de su casa a
su oficina maiwand trabajaba como
presentadora en el canal local en la cas
y era una reconocida activista por los
derechos civiles
el presidente afgano condenó el ataque y
pidió una investigación inmediata ningún
grupo ha reivindicado la autoría de los
hechos hasta el momento
finalizamos en eeuu un cohete starship
de la compañía spacex explotó el
miércoles durante un aterrizaje de
prueba en el estado de texas la nave
había despegado de la base y logró
ascender unos 12 kilómetros antes de
volver al punto donde debía posarse el
presidente de spacex y lo más que
explicó que el accidente se debió a que
la presión del tanque de combustible del
cohete era baja lo que causó que hubiese
una alta velocidad al momento de
aterrizar
por último vamos a una noticia que
enluta al fútbol a los 64 años murió el
ex futbolista retirado paolo rossi icono
de la selección italiana que consiguió
ganar el mundial de fútbol de 1982 según
la cadena arrai en la que eros y
trabajaba como comentarista el antiguo
delantero falleció como consecuencia de
una enfermedad incurable
así concluimos el informativo volvemos
en breve con más información feliz día
para todos
[Música]